llegó el momento de la información
económica en france 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañera
daniela blandón daniela bienvenida
iniciamos con los precios mundiales de
los alimentos que siguen al alza o la
valentina buenas noches pues el índice
de precios se incrementó en 3% en
octubre de 2021 por tercer mes
consecutivo hasta alcanzar máximos de
hace 10 años esto según la organización
de la onu para la agricultura y la
alimentación pero es clave también
compararlo frente a octubre del año
pasado porque en este caso las
variaciones del 31,3 por ciento
el resultado es ayudado por un fuerte
repunte en los precios mundiales de los
aceites vegetales y también de los
cereales sólo en octubre frente a
septiembre veamos los cereales se
incrementaron en 32 % y su alza en el
año supera el 20 por ciento el trigo
subió un 5% en el último mes pero casi
un 40% en el año el aceite vegetal por
su parte aumentó cerca del 10 por ciento
impulsado por cotizaciones más firmes en
diversas clases de aceites como el de
palma o el de soya o el de girasol
los lácteos subieron un 22 por ciento en
el décimo mes del año el valor de las
carnes fue el único que se redujo y
también lo hizo el del azúcar lo hizo en
un 70 7% marcando su tercer descenso a
nivel mensual y en el caso del azúcar en
el 1,8 por ciento
bueno pues igual una noticia preocupante
porque suben los precios pero no los
salarios si vamos ahora a argentina
porque el dólar el dólar volvió a tocar
un máximo histórico hay que explicar
primero valentina que en argentina
existe casi una decena de tipos de
dólares estadounidenses pero los dos más
comunes son el dólar en plaza minorista
es decir el que se vende de manera
oficial por parte del banco de la nación
y el informal también conocido como
dólar blue la brecha entre estas dos
cotizaciones es enorme y cada vez mayor
pero ambos llevan días tocando máximos
históricos- el más reciente de este
jueves debido a un mayor apetito de los
ciudadanos que buscan pues refugiarse en
esta moneda ante el constante aumento de
la inflación el dólar blue como vemos en
el gráfico alcanzó los 200 pesos
argentinos y el dólar a los 105 200 525
pesos este último se vende bajo
estrictas restricciones por parte del
gobierno las presiones cambiarias
valentina han aumentado en los últimos
días de cara a las elecciones
legislativas del 14 de noviembre que
generan incertidumbre no solamente en el
mercado financiero sino también entre el
ciudadano del común bueno y de argentina
nos vamos a eeuu porque las grandes
empresas se preparan para vacunar a sus
empleados de forma obligatoria este es
un anuncio de hace varias semanas pero
hasta el momento pues no se había hecho
oficial y es que el presidente yo vaivén
cumplió así una promesa y anunció la
obligatoriedad de que las empresas con
más de 100 empleados vacunen a su
plantilla a partir del 4 de enero y que
no se quiere a inocular pues tendrá que
practicarse una prueba semanal y usar
mascarillas en todo momento aunque las
grandes multinacionales aplauden la
medida dirigida a unos 84 millones de
personas ésta no ha caído muy bien en
algunas empresas sobre todo medianas y
pequeñas
de hecho valentina grupos o
empresariales
estatales y organizaciones religiosas
han prometido desafíos judiciales para
tratar de bloquearla por considerarla
ilegal pero nos vamos al otro lado del
mundo porque el canal de suez aumentará
sus tarifas así es la autoridad del
canal de suez anunció este jueves un
aumento del 6% en las tarifas que se
cobran por cruzar esta vía a partir de
febrero del próximo año lo que sí
quedará congelado son las tarifas a los
barcos que transporten gas natural
licuado y las de los cruceros turísticos
este último valentina por haber sido el
sector más afectado evidentemente por la
pandemia del cobi 19 vale recordar
también que este paso marítimo
egipcio entre mar rojo y el mar
mediterráneo sufrió un bloqueo de casi
una semana en marzo del año pasado y
provocó estragos en el transporte
marítimo mundial vamos ahora con los
indicadores económicos de la jornada
hubo resultados mixtos en wall street
aunque los índices nasdaq tecnológico y
standard and poor's continúan su racha
de máximos históricos en europa tercera
jornada consecutiva en récord para la
bolsa de parís y en américa latina la
bolsa paulo perdió más del 2% y
finalizamos con la cifra del día 11 mil
515 millones de euros esa fue la
ganancia neta del fabricante de
vehículos toyota motor en el tercer
trimestre de 2021 142 por ciento más que
el mismo período del año pasado daniela
pues muchas gracias por esta ampliación
a ustedes por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros que hay más en france 24
[Música]